what's up guys
bobby back with you here to talk about
the nikon zfc as a matter of fact i'm
recording this entire video on the nikon
zfc4k24p on this
and uh with the 28 f 2.8 se lens on it
so this is it
[Music]
i'm gonna go about this review a little
bit differently instead of doing my
standard you know talk about build
quality design usability lightroom final
thoughts i want to talk to you a little
bit about what the zfc stands for
because
yes it is
essentially a z50 with a flip out
rotatable display
and it's got some of the newer focusing
technology into it and it's got 20
megapixel aps-c sensor but
this camera signifies a lot more
this camera is going to educate a lot of
new content creators into the world of
nikon and into the history of nikon and
i think if they do this well
this is going to be some of the best
marketing nikon could have done in a
long period of time you know in my
personal opinion when i look at nikon
cameras and i see how they market them
out there it's always to wildlife
photographers sports photographers to
professionals
you don't see a lot of marketing to
the content creators of the or the
hobbyists or just the average consumer
out there i think they try to do that
with the z50 but it was a little bit
convoluted and the price point compared
to the z5 was as such that it was a
little bit like why don't i just go for
the z5 why do i even go over the z50 and
i know nikon had all these crazy
promotions and packages especially here
in singapore to sort of entice people
but i don't think it struck a chord as
much as i think this camera will do
the zfc is an homage to the fm2
everybody said that even nikon says it
and the fm2 was never a pro camera it's
not like the f2 or the f3 or the f4 the
f5 and f6 etc etc it was sort of that
pro-sumer
kind of hobbyist camera out there small
compact easy to carry around
you know
still took great images obviously it
depends on the film and the lens that
you're using for the most part and it
had you know a lot of the features that
most people needed
and i think the zfc for the most part
takes that dna and it brings it into the
digital realm now a lot of you out there
will be saying but bobby why why didn't
they make a full-frame camera i want a
full-frame camera i know i said the same
thing to nikon as well but after the
last couple weeks of using this camera i
kind of understand
why they decided to go with aps-c with
it because
aps-c 20 megapixels they can keep the
cost down
that's number one
which this camera is not meant for the
professional user
two
um
it you know you're not going to kill
your battery life with this thing you
can put a lot of images and a lot of
video on your sd card it's not gonna you
know you don't have to spend a lot of
money on all those things um you know
when i use the battery on this i can
shoot about seven eight hundred shots
before the battery goes dead i mean
that's a lot for a camera this size
so i can understand why they did all
that
yes i'm with you i hope they come up the
full frame version but for an experiment
for this first camera to bring people
into the nikon family into the nikon
lineage into the history i think this
was a really smart way to go and i
didn't think about this initially with
my first impressions i didn't it took me
a while using this camera to discover it
when we look at the build quality for
example it's not going to match an fm2
the fm2 was built like a tank you know
film cameras were always back then just
different materials back then the way
they were designed and built
i mean you pick up a mint condition fm2
today it looks beautiful and it holds up
well
digital cameras have a lifespan of a
couple years in terms of you know
before they're swapped out for new
cameras you know i mean yeah they can
last longer but you know what i mean
people change cameras a lot faster
nowadays so
this is not going to have that same
build quality it's not bad
but it's i wish it was a little bit
better but for our first attempt
okay i can accept some of the plastic
doors and some of the plastic buttons
and things like that but nikon
you can improve the zfc i know it's in
you and i hope you do that in the future
but it's not a deal breaker by any
stretch of the imagination but for me
using over the past couple weeks i've
enjoyed it the image quality i love
nikon color science i do to me nikon
color science is some of the best color
science out of any mirrorless camera
system currently on the market
the reds are accurate the greens are
accurate the the temperature is accurate
you know what i see with my naked eye
is what i'm getting out of the camera
maybe a little bit more enhanced but
enhanced in a good way
i love the metering on this camera
system especially when it has highlight
priority i don't know exact name of it
we'll put it here at the bottom of the
display in essence it basically allows
you not to clip your highlights to sort
of exposes for the highlights
so
your tones your colors
i mean everything just comes alive it's
beautiful
i mean the color profiles on this are
nice now of course they're just generic
named with letters i wish they had more
fun unique names like fujifilm did maybe
they can do that in the near future i
know you can sort of put your own
recipes in there i've seen other
photographers do that which is cool and
maybe they will build on that
but this camera allows that creativity
and allows that because most of the time
when you have a z72 and z62 you're using
it for a different type of photography
and different type of uh creator out
there this is going to be more for that
that daily creator that's going to take
food shots or blogger shots or vlogger
shots whatever it is or you know going
to travel around with this camera when
they can and they want to just
take beautiful images at the beach or at
a hotel and all that great stuff but
they want to do video you can do it with
this you got hdmi ports in this you got
all the everything you need
right it's for that that user and i
understand it i mean yeah on this
channel i review a lot of high-end
cameras and on the previous channel i
worked on i reviewed a lot of high-end
cameras but i also realized that the
market i'm talking to about those
cameras is quite small to be honest with
you someone's gonna spend five six seven
thousand dollars on a camera system they
gotta really love photography and
videography they really gotta love it if
they're just an average consumer
they're not going to spend that kind of
money the zfc is going to be where
they're going to put their money at
because they know that hey i can put a
thousand thousand five into this get a
lens give me a couple lenses
get the body
and that's all i want to spend and
that's all i want something that works
well and the camera does that um but you
know there are some things i do want to
point out in terms of its usability that
i think that are worth noting the dials
love them or love the retro feel
but if you want auto mode it's a little
bit hard to figure out there is no a on
the dials there's no distinct marking
for auto mode it is confusing i don't
even know if i've completely figured it
out yet even after a couple weeks of
using this camera exactly how to dial it
in i'm using more of the internal menu
system than anything else and it would
nice if you could actually just do
everything from the dial since you have
your iso dial there your shutter speed
and your exposure it'd been nice to just
okay i wanted to set iso to automatic i
want to set my shutter speed automatic i
want to control my so you want to play
around with that it would be nice to do
that now of course you have your pasm
modes on this which sort of override
certain things but
it is a little confusing and the buttons
on the back while it's nice to have all
those buttons again they're trying to
mesh pro with consumer and
it is a little bit convoluted i wish
they would have simplified this camera a
little bit more in my personal opinion
but
once you do spend some time with the
camera and you understand it
you're going to be fine with it
but i think that
outside of that man i really enjoy this
camera as a matter of fact
funny story here
this is the first nikon camera out of
the modern lineup that i've held
walked on the streets with and people
actually wanted to stop me and ask me
about the camera
they were like is that the new nikon zfc
can i can i hold it can i see it oh
what's it like what's it like to shoot
with is it a good camera and they're
like is it for sale and i'm like yeah
it's out in the stores right now they're
like whoa and they were so excited about
this camera
and
it was kind of took me back for a little
bit because i'm like well it kind of
does resemble a fujifilm camera if
you're you know for the average consumer
out there they would think that right
but
to them
they were excited that nikon had this
camera
so
nikon i think you're on the right track
with something here i really do i think
that
you know and through your marketing i
think you need to educate people about
the beautiful cameras the technology the
you know
what you guys did
for the photography industry as a whole
from the early 1900s to today i think
that needs to get get out there
yes
leica has just does this canon does this
to some extent but nikon you really
haven't tapped into this as much as i
feel you should so if you guys are
watching this out there i mean i even
told the marketing team you know yeah
i'm just a reviewer but i told you guys
i told them get the fm2 put it next to
the zfc show people this camera system
show
the homage show what was and what is i
think that's going to be exciting for
people i think people are going to
really love that
and i hope they do that i really do
because uh
this is a really cool camera i'm excited
for i really am i mean i play with a lot
of cameras you can see back here there's
a lot of gear back there but the zfc for
well it's a basic camera and it doesn't
have all the bells and whistles of a lot
of cameras i have here in the studio
it's been fun to use
um but nikon in the future can you make
the evf a little bit larger just a
little bit
i know you wanted to mimic the fm2 but
it's still a little small
high resolution okay if you want to do
that too that's not bad but a little bit
bigger would be great anyway
those are my thoughts on the zfc as you
can tell the video functionality on this
is fantastic it's been tracking me the
entire time i've been in focus the
entire time af c for that matter so
there you have it video is great with
that guys take care stay safe like this
video does help out our channel a lot
any questions you have on the zfc hit me
in the comment section below i'll try to
answer those for you um
but yeah
i'm a fan of it and i'm really happy
nikon went this route and i hope they
continue to do so with that guys take
care and i'll chat to you soon bye